en el donbass los bomberos de los globe
jiang se están llevando suministros a
una población es un trabajo que hacen en
toda la ciudad todos los días
estamos repartiendo agua a la gente y
ayudándola porque es lo días que no
tiene agua hace un mes la planta de
bombeo y filtración de sjl obiang
situada al este quedó cortada en los
combates lo que hizo imposible su
reparación las autoridades de la ciudad
se aseguran de que los bomberos sepan
que se necesita y donde tenemos una
lista con las direcciones
muéstrame la lista por qué
filas como éstas se acumulan cada día
pero tras un mes de escasez la paciencia
se agota
dígale al alcalde que necesitamos dos
camiones para cada edificio no es
suficiente tengo que venir tan lejos
todos los días para conseguir agua
cerraron el gas sellaron todo y bueno
buena suerte en que está pensando este
presidente es el ens que piensa con la
cabeza con los pies porque ha cerrado
todo a mí
[Música]
el bombardeo empeora
ramas
bueno
fue una bomba de racimo lo que creó esta
onda expansiva y una bomba de racimo
después de la cobertura los bomberos
tienen que moverse rápidamente de aquí
unos 15 incendios se están produciendo
alrededor de es lo bianco
llamamos la unidad 1 en camino
[Aplausos]
gruesos también pueden estar en camino y
demasiado rápido tras la caída del issys
chance a poco más de 70 kilómetros al
este es lo bien que ahora se encuentra
directamente en el camino de los
objetivos de vladimir putin para hacerse
con el control total de la región del
tomba